nous sommes toujours en compagnie de
benoît hamon
qu'edouard
non ma vie
et nous accueillons notre invité du
samedi 20 heures ce soir xavier mathieu
bonsoir
alors xavier vous êtes le plus
emblématique des responsables syndicaux
qui sont apparus ces derniers mois vous
êtes le leader des conti ses salariés de
l'usiné continental de clairoix qui a
été fermé pour être délocalisés en
tunisie en turquie en roumanie et pour
manifester votre colère contre cette
fermeture vous avez avec vos camarades
saccagé la sous préfecture de l'oise à
compiègne acte pour lequel ont été
condamnés et vous êtes devenu un symbole
de la lutte ouvrière en france n'a pas
saccagé la sous préfecture parce que la
boîte à fermer c'est parce qu'on s'est
un peu foutu de notre gueule au
gouvernement nous a mené en bateau et
voilà c'est un petit coup de colère
voilà on en parlera à 21
[Musique]
xavier mathieu re bonsoir vous êtes né
le 15 mai 1965 à paris dans le 14e et
votre grande gage d'où la tenue de votre
père un auvergnat qui se posent à tracy
le val dans l'oise en 68 pour gérer un
chantier de charbon vous dites mon père
c'était l'emmerdeur public numéro un ben
ouais c'est du coup comme quoi la
génétique et laisse des traces c'est
vrai que votre père c'était un des
premiers à faire chier les patrons avec
l'amiante tout ça ça fait sans exagérer
au moins trente cinq ans que j'en
entends parler par mon père qui refusait
déjà d'utiliser des gants en amiante à
l'usiné qui voulait absolument mettre
des masques quand il touchait l'amiante
et tous qui refusaient qui se faisait
traiter de d'emmerdeur public numéro un
alors l'école j'ai fait incapable de
rester assise ou debout terre vous aimez
pas trop l'école arrêté à l'âge de 16
ans fait un cap2 bouche et vous devenez
boucher et à l'époque vous venez d'avoir
un enfant et les 4500 francs par mois
que la boucherie vous rapporte c'est pas
assez ça tombe bien continental le
fabricant de pneus décide d'embaucher
300 personnes à 7500 francs par mois
jusqu'à 3000 de plus par mois c'est pas
mal mais le problème c'est qu'il faut
faire les trois-huit bas tout est
semaine tu change d'horaire tu bouffes
jamais la même heure tu te couches
jamais la même heure tu vois tes gosses
un jour sur deux une semaine sur deux
des fois tu les vois pas et voilà donc
j'ai appris avec stupéfaction qui est
des gens qui savaient pas ce qu'était
les trois-huit les 3,8 ont flingué votre
famille quoi ouais je pense que j'ai pas
été un bon père pense enfin
j'ai pas été vraiment un bon père de
famille mes enfants parce que j'ai pas
toujours été là j'ai la fatigue
à fait que voilà j'ai pas été forcément
un bon père même si ils disent que c'est
pas vrai même si mes enfants sont sont
fiers de moi aujourd'hui moi je pense
que j'aurais pu faire beaucoup plus pour
eux voilà la souffrance à l' usine c'est
pas seulement les 3,8 ce n'est pas
seulement le rythme de travail ou les
changements de rythme de travail sera
encore pire c'est la souffrance physique
terne et en dignité douleurs dans le dos
le problème de vertèbres les corps
broyés des ouvriers alors dans le temps
les anciens c'était les travaux forcés
bon c'était pas mieux mais aujourd'hui
c'est c des travaux qui sont toujours
répétitif répétitif répétitif et les
articulations les tendons pet ne
tiennent plus on dit quand on parle des
retraites que la durée de vie s'allonge
mais pour les ouvriers la durée de vie
s'allonge pas c'est toujours à
3,64 moyenne je pense quoi oui bien sûr
non mais je pense que le moi tu sais
j'ai vu j'ai vu j'ai vu pendant des
années
des potes partir à la retraite et puis
j'ai vu pendant des années sur le
panneau à l'entrée des armes
d'informations telles pote était mort
deux ans trois ans après alors les
horaires de merde les boulots crevant il
y aurait de quoi à détester son travail
pas du tout au contraire d'y aller les
ouvriers adorent leur usine ils sont
fiers de bosser continental la machine
qui leur casse le dos il l'appelle ma
machine comme ils disent ma femme
attachement au canton les mecs parler de
leur machine tu sais les mecs ils se
sont battus c'est pas seulement pour
sauver leur famille si c'était pour ces
leur usine c'est la boîte tu as les mecs
ça fait un an un an et demi temps à
plein il passe même plupart lusine
chemin l usine il est vite ils peuvent
pas ça un traumatisme mais grave alors
le volet souci que vous avez rencontrés
chez conti c'est un an après votre
arrivée
quand la direction veut augmenter les
cadences voilà vous gueulez ne vous êtes
pas encore syndiqués à l'époque
j'étais un des premiers ouvrir ma gueule
et puis à l'époque j'ai fini à la cgt
parce que j'ai failli me faire virer par
le patron et c'est la cgt qui m'a
défendu donc je me suis dit le 11 mars
2009 donc la fermeture de l'usiné
annoncée et pour ça le directeur
allemand ont fait le déplacement et il
dit pensez aussi aux actionnaires eux
aussi ont besoin de faire des bénéfices
pour vivre c'est sûr elle gémit paquet
de kleenex dans la gueule et on parle de
radicalisation partout en france mais
moi je voudrais quand même dire un sacré
coup de chapeau à tous là toute la
classe ouvrière parce que la
radicalisation il n'a pas eu d'enfant
jamais eu de drame si chez les ouvriers
chez france télécom tu vois il ya eu des
suicides il ya plein de gens qui se
suicident qu'ils foutent l'envié en
l'air j'ai compte il ya déjà des nombres
divorce mais il sait qu'en valais
patrons n'ont jamais jamais alors cette
boîte c'est quand même 27 millions
d'euros de bénéfice quoi je veux dire ça
va quand même y sont pas à la rue alors
là bon quand on vous annonce la
fermeture de l'usiné vous commencez à
pas dormir vous dormez trois heures par
nuit ouais ouais ouais c'est c'est un
combat c'est un des combats c'est un des
combats de notre vie déclenché
le 1er lexomil quand même aulas ouais
ouais j'ai tourné au lexomil parce que
parce que contrairement à ce que peut
penser et j'ai remarqué souvent j'ai
rencontré beaucoup de leaders de lutte
et c'est un peu tous les mêmes tu sais
on est tous des grandes gueules mais à
la fin à l'intérieur c'est un chamallow
c'est je suis un bis le habile comme
c'est pas possible quand je me couchais
j'y arrive pas je n'arrivais pas à
dormir de ce qui s'était passé la veille
je n'arrivais pas à dormir de ce qu'elle
est passée de lendemain alors le pire
c'est qu'en échange de cette rue non
fermeture les ouvriers de continental
avait accepté en fait des sacrifices les
gens vont accepter de revenir à 40
heures c'est le travailler plus mais ni
plus est dans cet accord de 40 heures
aussi ce qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'il
ya eu aussi le 30 les transferts de
charge qui est une loi de sarkozy c'est
à dire qu'on transfère par exemple des
primes d'intérêt des primes de vacances
ou des primes de fin d'année en
intéressement pour plus le payer de
charges ayant aussi la loi tepa sur les
heures supplémentaires qui ont été un
véritable fiasco puisque on sait ce que
comment ça finit en fin de compte que tu
fais des ya des chômeurs et on fait
faire des heures supplémentaires aux
gens et en plus parlants par le même
biais on veut faire travailler les gens
plus longtemps face et il ya des choses
qu'on n'arrive pas à nous appeler alors
les ouvriers évidemment refusent la
fermeture vont devant les tribunaux
persuadés qu'ils vont gagner mais le
verdict est favorable à continental et
la colère explose incontrôlée quoi et
c'est le saccage de la sous-préfecture
de l'oise à compiègne tu sais j'ai dire
c'est le le désarroi des gens il a été à
l'auteur délai de l'espérance qu'ils
avaient jenlain personne n'a envisagé
une seule seconde qu'on allait perdre ma
seule erreur si je peux en avoir une
c'est d'avoir annoncé dans la sous
préfecture qu'on avait perdu mes temps
mais moi j'ai pas réfléchi une seule
seconde explosé et voilà le seul fait
choper en fait vous avez été filmée il y
avait cette télé jour-là avoriaz mais
canal il y avait là cinq l'a6 france 2
france 3 tous étaient là tf1 à la fin
tous sont venus nous voir nous disons
toutes les images seront floutés sauf
une il y en a qu'une qui enfin une qu'il
avait dit qu'il l'a pas fait c'est tf1
un puisqu'à cause c'est que vous êtes
fait choper bah oui puisque en plus ce
qui est marrant c'est le jour du
tribunal le même le président du
tribunal a dit magnifique pour une fois
c'est facile de travailler avec des
images pareilles il s'est pas levé mais
presque il a regardé dans la salle il a
fait merci tf1 c'est fort quand même
c'est vraiment un bon vous avez votre
tripartite ce qui veut dire que l'état
intervient il vous laisse plus vous face
à continental donc l'état intervient
doute tripartite vous décider à ce
moment-là du plan social j'ai bien
négocié quand même sorti la cinquante
mille euros doublement des indemnités
légales congé de conversion de 80 %
jusqu'à fin 2011
ça va pas par rapport à un plan social
oui là on aurait préféré tout ce que nos
djazila reste debout mais la lutte a
payé et l'exemplarité de la lutte ça a
été une véritable démocratie ouvrière
tout s'est décidé en assemblée générale
nous les les délégués on s'est mis
minable
ça veut dire que moi je représente est
plus que moi même c'est à dire que quand
j'allais en assemblée générale y avait
900 mec avait 900 mais qui votaient pour
leur peau voilà justement justement vous
en tant que délégué syndical vous auriez
pu profiter d'un système de licenciement
beaucoup plus favorable en fait mais
vous vous êtes dit non moi je vais être
traité comme les autres ouais il y en a
tout le monde n'a pas fait choix on est
trois ou quatre de la cgt avoir demandé
à l'inspecteur du travail à être traités
comme les 11 120 1 voilà mais c'est
normal moi j'ai signé un accord c'est
normal mais c'est bien alors procès du
saccage de la sous préfecture il
réservant de témoins de moralité qui
sont venus marie george buffet olivier
besancenot cécile duflot jean luc
mélenchon et hasard parce qu'on vous a
pas du tout invité pour ça tous les deux
vous étiez là benoît ça faisait
longtemps que j'avais pas eu
la pression avant de parler on fait des
télés on parle et c est là bas c'est
quand même une bagarre exemplaire qui
l'ont conduite et et c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que tout le monde aime mieux
un résultat des courses donc les dégâts
ont été estimés à 50 de 1000 euros bon
voilà trois bureaux l'état dit
l'assurance ne rembourse 40000 donc les
continue doivent 12000 euros et ce qui
est extraordinaire aussi c'est qu'à ce
moment là le pognon et arrivait de
partout de france d'italie d'allemagne
c'est la solidarité ouvrière qui va
payer qui va payer tous les dommages et
tous les toutes les condamnations toutes
les amendes c'est la solidarité ouvrière
tous les pays qui vont payer et ça ça me
fait ça me fait chaud au coeur vous êtes
cgt mais thibault on n'a pas beaucoup vu
quand même un
gros mot ça non ouais c'est
qu'il est content en fait la
radicalisation thinel pareil ça a été un
débat sur sur thibault surre sur le fait
qu'on dise que j'ai reproché à thibaut
pas être venu dans le vide j'en ai rien
à cirer que ce soit dans les îles ne
sais pas ça la vérité est la limite
qu'on dise que c'est pas son boulot
ouais c'est pas son boulot c'est pas son
goût loi non plus à lui aux autres
politiques et sont venus ils sont venus
mais je voudrais bien tirer enfin
remercier quand même la fédération de la
chimie parce que eux ont toujours été là
depuis le début ensuite il ya la
proposition de reclassement que
continental est obligé de vous faire ou
on vous propose 137 euros par mois pour
aller travailler en tunisie bon là ce
qu'il faut dire quand même à leur
décharge c'est qu'ils sont obligés de le
faire et que les chaussettes olympia qui
l'ont pas fait ont été condamnés à deux
millions et demi d'euros d'amendé sauf
qu'il ya encore un coup tordu là dessous
c'est que le medef et le grand patronat
ça fait des années que comment dire que
l'obligation de reclassement ils veulent
le virer alors ils font exprès justement
de proposer des situations tellement il
manquerait croyable que justement ils
veulent se mettre autour d'une table
pour dire vous avez vu n'obligez faire
ça c'est dégueulasse pour tout le monde
se mette autour d'une table et vire
cette obligation de reclassement ensuite
on retrouve les conti dans toutes les
luttes qui a eu donc vous êtes devenu un
petit peu les robins des bois chez new
fabris chez total chez sodimatex chez
goodyear honnêtement vous a aucune
chance de retrouver du boulot yahia moi
je vais vous dire je serai patron je ne
prendrai pas
témoin je vais te dire j'ai vécu g45
balle et j'ai vécu la plus belle
expérience
sociale et humaine de ma vie quoi qu'il
arrive je vais dire je m'en fous moi ce
qu'il cherche dans la vie c'est pas la
fortune c'est la richesse et la richesse
vient d'ici ça vient de là le reste je
m'en fous c'est quoi c'est une baraque
une copine et ramasser des morilles
voilà c'est à laisser aller aux mauries
avoir une une copine des enfants et puis
il ya une chose qui m'importe dans la
vie tu es quand au bout de ma vie
restera la fierté de mes parents de mes
enfants et de celle que j'aime le reste
je m'en fout comme de l'an 40 ce sera le
monde n'a pas un merci et pour être sûr
de ne rien rater de dinars 10 tubes
abonnez vous je m'étais un peu ce bleu